this is a beautiful video this is a
perfect video that i'm going to play for
you
this is what you call a political
trapeze artist
flying around wildly trying to keep it
all together
i've told you before that republicans
have been causing a problem
for themselves in georgia because on the
one hand they're insisting and trump has
been insisting
that the november presidential election
was rigged against him
he won but it was rigged and so joe
biden
claims to have won the votes can't be
trusted the georgia republican governor
can't be trusted
the georgia republican secretary of
state is in on it they're bad people
it's all rigged and at the same time
trump and the two republican senate
candidates in georgia kelly lefler
and david perdue these are the races
that will determine who controls the
senate after their january 5th runoffs
they've been saying
yeah it was rigged against trump and
make sure to vote for us on january 5th
what because the obvious question is
we we there's a contradiction there the
election was
rigged against trump and presumably also
rigged against them in november
maybe loffler and perdue would have won
had it not been rigged
but because of the rigging now they have
runoffs but wouldn't the runoffs also be
rigged by their own logic
this all came to a glorious crescendo
yesterday on fox and friends when
leftler was interviewed and she was
asked
why wouldn't the january runoffs be just
as rigged as the november election and
she just can't she literally cannot
explain it take a look at this
we've heard from the president who said
that the election was stolen from him
that it was rigged in november so for
the people of georgia who are thinking
about
early voting what can you say to them
they've heard
the election was rigged in november so
why vote now
well steve great question because we've
built a robust organization to make sure
that every legal vote is counted and
every illegal vote is thrown out
so what's different now than it was in
november where it's no longer rigged
yeah so we're in the courts right now
asking for better
signature verification processes a
bipartisan verification
to have consistent verification county
to county
as well as the addition of four thousand
poll watchers we also have a statewide
organization getting out the vote
one thousand workers going across the
state backed by 40 000 volunteers
if we vote we will win if we don't vote
we will lose the country
we are the firewall to socialism and you
saw in my debate last week
i'm running against the most radically
liberal candidate that has ever run for
the senate
he's someone that would defund the
police he refused to renounce socialism
we have to push back against this
radical agenda of the left and it's up
to georgia voters to do that
great question she says and and listen
to her
her explanations we now have an
organization to count every legal vote
well right but that's that's you're
doing that for november how does that
even relate to what has changed
in the system she says we're in the
courts well but none of that's going
anywhere
and then she says we're really working
hard to get out the vote get out the
vote is campaigning it has nothing to do
with rigging
and then she just goes into socialism
and attacks her opponent rafael
warnock she can't answer the question so
she just has her buzz words from the
debate
but this was a totally different
question if you believe it was rigged in
november
and your vote wasn't counted accurately
or at all
why would you vote this time because
nothing has changed
and it's a great question and she says
well because my opponents are radical
okay that's not really an answer and
it's actually a disaster
and really depressing that these races
in georgia are even close
but they are close in john ossoff versus
david perdue the average of recent
polling is oss of plus one
which means it's tied could go either
way which means you have to vote
in leffler vs warnock it's warnock plus
1.6 again
whether you do or don't trust these
polls you have to vote if we trust
these polls it's close and we have to
vote if we don't trust these polls
we don't know how close it is so we have
to vote
either way we have to vote and it would
be a major
accomplishment major accomplishment to
be able to after everything that's gone
down
take control of the senate 50 50 with
kamala
as the deciding vote january 5th is the
day
just a few weeks left and we will know
who is ultimately going to control the
senate
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars
just for using their free service at
privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now i love it
it saves me a bunch of headaches it's
completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works when you pay for something online
or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set spending
limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want i especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
pacman